[Music]
we're hearing a lot about the Internet
of Things how your many many devices are
becoming networked computers and many of
these devices are you know $10 thing
that you buy and you put on your shelf
and you have it for a year and you throw
it away I think not a lot of attention
is being played paid to the security of
those kinds of devices in some sense the
companies that are making them can't
afford to do it but they they can leave
long-standing vulnerabilities the
automotive industry is another
interesting example a typical American
modern automobile has somewhere between
30 and 100 what are called embedded
control units but embedded control unit
is just a computer some of them are very
very small and run very simple code
native on the hardware some of them are
full-blown Linux computers or Windows
computers and our networked a modern car
has four to five network connections
where the code the computers on the car
talked to computers outside of the car
so an example is there's a Bluetooth
connection so that your cell phone can
talk to the car so that you can play
your music from your phone on the car
you can talk on the cell phone without
having your having to use your hands
there's also a telematics unit which is
the thing that if you get in an accident
will arrange to call 911 or have the
paramedics come that service which is
really useful and very it's a great
safety feature means that your car has a
cell phone number and that it's possible
to communicate with your car over that
cell phone connection hackers can use
those network connections to remotely
break in to the computer system that's
on your car and white hat hackers have
shown they can do that and then they can
then rewrite any of the software on the
car replace the code that was
legitimately put there by the car
manufacturer with whatever code they
want to have there and a typical in a
modern car pretty much all of the
functionality of the car is now
controlled by software so braking is
controlled site by software because you
really want to have anti-lock braking
steer acceleration is controlled by
software because of cruise control and
that when you like you really want to
have a car that can produce parallel
parking for you and that means steering
is under software control the locks are
under software controls so you can push
the key fob button and have your locks
open essentially all of the
functionality
if cars are under software control and
for the most part that's a really good
thing having it be under software
control means that you can get increased
functionality you can have improved
safety features you can get upgrades as
the car companies figure out how to do
things better all that's really good
the downside is that because it's
controlled by software if an attacker
can come in and replace that software
then they can control the braking and
the acceleration and the locks and
everything that it was under software
control so we're starting to see theft
rings for example that are using
electronic hacking in order to steal
cars more easily Lloyd's of London
recently stopped insuring Land Rovers in
England unless the Land Rovers were
garaged
in a locked facility because they were
being stolen too frequently so that's
the kind of state-of-the-art of the
automotive industry the question is well
why isn't it better so one starting
point is it's it's really hard to get
good security you have to do tons of
things right it costs money so the car
industry could improve the security of
their cars and hopefully they will
eventually that improvement will cost
them money and the car industry doesn't
have huge profit margins they can't
really afford to invest in the security
unless they can recoup the cost
associated with that investment by
passing the cost on to the consumer so
that means the price of the car is going
to be higher so then why is the consumer
are gonna go buy the car that's more
than the equivalent car from a different
manufacturer well typically the answer
is well you do advertising you explain
to the consumer why they're getting more
value for this extra cost the problem is
if you if you imagine car company a car
company starting a ad campaign to
explain their car is more cyber secure
most consumers these days probably think
their car was already cyber secure they
didn't realize that their car could be
hacked into so the result of such an
advertising campaign could in fact be to
make people afraid to buy any new car
whatsoever rather than causing them to
buy a particular car so I think an
advertising approach to motivating
consumers to pay slightly more for a
particular car is not really viable so
that means all of the cars have to have
basically all of the companies have to
do it at the same time they all have to
do this extra investment that basically
if the price of all cars goes up by a
little
but then there's no longer this
differentiation between manufacturers
and consumers would be choosing between
cars that all have roughly the same
level of security going back just a bit
another reason why the car companies
can't advertise on the security is
suppose one car company actually did go
and invest a ton in making their cars
more secure and then they advertise
their car was more secure that's kind of
a painting a big target on your back as
far as the hacker community is concerned
certain individuals would take that as a
challenge and they would go like they
would you sort of get some number of
credibility for hacking into any car but
if you hack into the car that is from
the company that is advertising that
their cars are secure you get way more
credibility if they find a vulnerability
and then publish it that car all of a
sudden has less is less secure than the
other cars that might actually have more
vulnerabilities but no one has
discovered it because the vulnerability
is public and people know it exists and
therefore can exploit it so it's this
weird situation where although the car
and some absolute sense is more secure
in a practical sense it's less secure
because there's a publicly known
vulnerability so advertising is bad both
because it could scare away consumers
entirely and they could direct hackers
to your specific car decreasing the
security of that car and as a result so
we're left with how do you get sort of
the car industry as a whole to produce
more secure cars and that requires some
kind of external motivation they might
decide to do it because it's just the
right thing to do typically companies
are motivated by financial reasons not
they usually can't afford to do things
just because of the right thing to do in
terms of outside forces one outside
force would be government regulation so
cars many years ago we're very unsafe
right Ralph Nader wrote famously unsafe
at any speed and that prompted federal
regulations there's the five star safety
crash rating system for example that
that created a regime where cars were
tested for their safety and given scores
and consumers could then use those
scores and making their decisions I
think creating such a regime in the
current political climate is unlikely
another possibility is the insurance
company might the insurance industry
might start to
you impose put pressure financial
pressure on car industry we saw that
with the Lloyd's of London refusing to
insure Land Rovers that weren't garaged
and locked facilities because of
electronic theft that if the insurance
companies start to notice that certain
kinds of cars are getting hacked into
with negative consequences for theft or
for for accidents they might increase
the insurance premiums on that
particular brand and those insurance
premiums might then drive consumers to
cars that don't have those
characteristics and that might then
motivate the car industry to improve the
security that's kind of a long chain but
at the moment I think that's my best
guess as to how we'll get better cyber
security in in our cars but I think the
car industry is in some sense
representative of many other industries
so like medical devices are another
domain things like pacemakers and
insulin pumps they're relatively simple
computer systems that are networked to
other computers like it makes sense for
a pacemaker to have a Wi-Fi device so a
doctor can monitor how the hearts are
doing but once you have that Wi-Fi
connection a hacker can use it to go in
and modify the code in the pacemaker
there are basically lots of examples of
industries where things that previously
weren't computers at all are now not
only computers but they're networked
computers and over time those industries
will need to accept that their network
computers and start to apply security
techniques so that the systems are more
secure
[Music]